well february is black history month and
many in our community are looking to
support black owned businesses
here in las vegas new businesses are
popping up despite the challenges of the
pandemic
kate houston is live from charleston and
casino center where munchie's smokehouse
barbecue
is serving up some unique dishes in a
pretty unusual time
kate
yes that's right we're here at munchies
smoked house where they're taking
classic barbecue
and they're really just adding a fun
twist to it with dishes like tri-tip mac
and cheese
barbecue ramen and their fan favorite
rib tips
as a recently opened black-owned
business they're hoping to cultivate a
community here of all different styles
of food
i think our concepts are really fun and
they're new this is a tri-tip
for the past four months chaute ducharme
and brandon jackson have been selling a
wide variety of barbecue dishes from
their new food truck
munchies smokehouse barbecue we just
wanted to do a very different fusion
style barbecue
we make nachos out of 20 different chips
it's all a munchie style
what started as a dream soon became a
necessity when chaute lost her job
right before the pandemic was just
scared for my family
really honestly scared of like where we
were going to be if we were going to be
homeless
so i had to start thinking about what we
were going to do
to make some money after a few setbacks
the food truck made its debut this past
october
since then the lines haven't stopped
it's a great feeling it went from
not knowing if it was going to be a good
decision to
with super bowl coming up just turning
away too many people
as a black-owned business jackson says
many customers have stopped by to try
their food for that very reason
and congratulate them on their success
and our smoker can hold 600 pounds of
meat at one time
now the duo is looking to support other
black-owned businesses through a
pan-african food truck night
really just try to create something here
in las vegas i think that
there definitely needs to be something
that incorporates everybody not just
black but we're talking about like the
afro
latinos and our caribbean folks and all
of that
although the food truck has only been
open for a short time they're looking at
the possibility
of a brick and mortar location and
potentially franchising
to other parts of the united states
reporting from charleston and south
casino boulevard tonight kate houston
8 news now